to play a gay role
yeah is very you know you i'm sure you
met with your agent and you said hey
wait a second
heath ledger and i thinking of doing
this movie brokeback mountain blah blah
blah blah and no one knew what was going
to
be
thinking of doing a romantic film right
that's that's a huge so jake isn't that
a huge career decision i mean a lot of
thought goes into that ah
man it's weird i don't know i don't
think
yeah first of all i was angry directing
it at the time so i mean at least coming
from where i come from it's like
angley is like uh is a genius so
in my opinion it was like oh wow it's a
movie with angley so it wasn't it wasn't
just that
that was part of it you know thinking oh
my god this person is going to make it
in a really amazing way
but no there wasn't like this it wasn't
calculated like that
you know and i don't think any of us
thought it was going to be what it
became no way
i mean and so i you know in a way maybe
someone should have sat me down
and had a little talk with me about
about that but but at the same time like
uh you know it moved me the script moved
me and i was like can't [ __ ] it you know
what i mean
i'll do it yeah and i also you know i
really really we had no idea what it's
gonna be like
that to me is a big decision it's
pivotal because you are a leading man
guys would take gay characters and they
would really have to think it through
yeah because it was like you know
average joe is saying uh he's gay
that's inevitable and i don't buy him as
a romantic uh
you know male lead but uh i mean and
then you and then you got nominated for
the oscar for that
right so was that amazing yeah [ __ ]
everyone it's a good decision
you